SERENA AMMIRATI: Looking
at this book page by page
and trying to decipher, read,
and transcribe whatever is
there takes an enormous
amount of time.
It would require an
army of paleographers.
ELENA NIEDDU: What I am excited
the most about machine learning
is that it enabled us to
solve problems that up to 10,
15 years ago we
thought unsolvable.
ELENA NIEDDU: Before using any
kind of machine learning model,
we needed to collect data first.
You have thousands of images of
dogs and cats in the internet,
but there's very little
images of ancient manuscripts.
We built our own custom web
application for crowdsourcing.
And we involved high school
students to collect the data.
I didn't know much about
machine learning in general.
But I found it very easy
to create a TensorFlow
environment.
When we were trying
to figure out
which model worked best for us,
Keras was the best solution.
The production model runs on
TensorFlow layers, an estimator
interface.
We experimented with
binary classification,
with fully connected networks.
And finally, we moved to
convolutional neural network
and multiclass classification.
ELENA NIEDDU: When it comes to
recognizing single characters,
we can get 95% average accuracy.
SERENA AMMIRATI: This will
have an enormous impact.
In a short period
of time, we will
have a massive quantity
of historical information
available.
ELENA NIEDDU: I just think
solving problems is fun.
It's a game against myself,
and how good I can do.